[Musik]
Kolumbien liegt zwischen dem Pazifik und
dem karibischen Meer und ist heute ein
schlüsselstandort in Bezug auf die
Wirtschaftskrise in Venezuela der
ehemalige Präsident von Kolumbien Juan
Manuel Santos der 2016 den Nobelpreis
bekam für seinen Plan den 50-Jährigen
Bürgerkrieg gegen die Fahrt zu beenden
trat 2018 nach zwei Amtszeiten zurück
heute steht Kolumbien wirtschaftlich
besser da als Venezuela und andere
Länder in Lateinamerika
[Musik]
der Aufstieg der kryptowährungen kam mit
dem neuen kolumbianischen Präsidenten
Ivan Duke und seinem Versprechen die
Steuern für Krypto und Datenbank
blockchain Unternehmen zu senken die
Nachricht wurde am 29 August von der
lokalen Zeitung El Tiempo veröffentlicht
ich fahre diesmal nach Medellin der
zweitgrößten Stadt Kolumbiens Medellin
hat eine geschätzte Bevölkerung von 2,5
Millionen Menschen die Positionen als
sekundäre Industriestadt in Kolumbien
war einer der wichtigsten Faktoren um
die Krise in den 80er und 90er Jahren zu
überwinden
die Metro ein massiver öffentlicher
Verkehrsdienst ist heute der Stolz der
Stadt
als Stadt des ewigen Frühlings wegen des
tollen Wetters das ganze
einer der aktivsten Dash Gemeinden der
Welt
Medellin ist auch das Zuhause von coin
Logic ATM solution
Eduards Eigentümer von Dash red Samuel
Barbosa Dash teamentwickler und George
Donnelly Eigentümer von Dash Colombia
mein Ziel ist es herauszufinden wie die
Entwicklung in Kolumbien abgelaufen ist
von einem einzigen Geschäft das im
januar 2018 Dash akzeptierte bis zu den
mehr als 350 Unternehmen die es heute
sind und wie Kolumbien eins der
wichtigsten Länder war während der
Wirtschaftskrise in Venezuela
bis heute hat Kolumbien Millionen von
Flüchtlingen aus Venezuela aufgenommen
und es spielt eine unglaublich wichtige
Rolle in dieser schrecklichen
humanitären Krise
auch die dash-gemeinde arbeitet an einem
Bildungsprogramm um eine Lösung zu
finden für die Menschen Massen die nach
Kolumbien kommen
[Musik]
sie sind hier einfach um zu arbeiten um
Geld zu verdienen um es dann in ihren
Familien in Venezuela zu schicken wir
können nicht mehr nur hoffen glauben
oder dem System der Regierung oder den
Banken vertrauen
wir brauchen kryptowährungen und wir
brauchen sie jetzt
[Musik]
wir sind früh raus heute und unser Ziel
ist es zwischen 10 und 15 Läden in der
Stadt zu finden ihren Status zu prüfen
und sie für Dash zu gewinnen
diesmal wurde ich auch von der Gemeinde
eingeladen auf ihren Events zu sprechen
und ich wurde von Nelson Kamera von
camerate technologies begleitet
außerdem waren Lorenzo Aurelia von Dash
Venezuela und orenia Cala die Gründerin
von der Venezuela dabei
wir nahmen einige Taxis und fuhren durch
die ganze Stadt um zu sehen wie der
erste Kontakt zu neuen Händlern ist und
wie Dash angenommen wird
wie geht man auf die Händler zu geht man
selbst hin oder schickt man jemanden um
sie davon zu überzeugen dieses magische
internetgeld zu verwenden gib uns einen
Tipp
also ich gehe hin und sage ihnen dass
das digitale Geld Dash in Medellin
angekommen ist jede Woche geben wir
Leuten ein bisschen Dash und sie suchen
nach Orten wo sie es ausgeben können ich
möchte Ihnen neue Kunden bringen und ich
erzähle Ihnen alles was Sie über der ich
wissen müssen
ich sorge dafür dass sie kein Geld
verlieren wollen sie es versuchen unser
ganzes Team hier ist sehr erfolgreich
mit diesem Ansatz denn welcher
Geschäftsmann will keine neuen Kunden
ich war bisher in ein paar Restaurants
hier in Medellin die Dash akzeptieren
nach dem Event heute Abend werde ich mir
das ansehen es gibt sogar einen ganzen
Supermarkt wo man mit dashzahlen kann
das ist aufregend und es ist interessant
zu sehen wie sich kryptowährungen in
Dritte Welt Ländern schneller verbreitet
als in Europa oder den USA wie sehen sie
diese Entwicklung und wo glauben sie
wird Medellin in Sachen Dash in ein paar
Monaten stehen
ich denke das wird ziemlich verrückt
unsere größte Herausforder ist jetzt wie
wir den Leuten Dash sicher verkaufen
können denn sie wollen das
glücklicherweise haben wir hier ein
Partnerunternehmen coin Logic das
verteilt Geldautomaten in der ganzen
Stadt ich denke jeden Tag ich habe hier
keine Kontrolle mehr das passiert alles
ohne mich aber das ist gut
von Tür zu Tür gehen ist eine extrem
harte Aufgabe zum ersten Mal auf einen
Händler zuzugehen oder mit jemandem
erneut Kontakt aufzunehmen der Dash
akzeptiert aber noch keine Kunden hat
manchmal hören wir ja sie sind sehr
willkommen und das einzurichten und
unser Geschäft in die dash-gemeinde
aufzunehmen aber manchmal hören wir auch
nein wir sind noch nicht interessiert
also geht der Rundgang weiter und nach
einem langen Tag ist es Zeit nach Hause
zu gehen und sich etwas auszuruhen
[Musik]
Veranstaltungstage sind immer meine
liebsten Tage in der Woche
hunderte von Menschen kommen um zu
verstehen was kryptowährungen sind und
was Dash ist
die Gelegenheit für sie ein Wallet
runterzuladen und ihre ersten
Erfahrungen mit Dash zu machen
ich fasse das auch in einer Präsentation
zusammen spreche über die Geschichte des
Geldes und wie wichtig es ist zu
verstehen dass Geld heute nur ein Blatt
Papier ist
dieser Veranstaltung lief es genauso und
es waren einige Leute von Dash Columbia
Dash Venezuela und dashbourzel dabei
ein teamentwickler und Mitglieder der
örtlichen dash-gemeinde die schon dabei
helfen ein kryptowährungssystem in
Medellin zu etablieren
[Musik]
während der Veranstaltung hatten wir in
einem anderen Konferenzraum rund 30
Geschäftsleute die schon Dash
akzeptieren
sie bildeten einen Teil des Events weil
sie über ihre täglichen Erfahrungen mit
der kryptowährung berichten konnten
es war eine tolle Gelegenheit
verschiedene Produkte mit Dash zu kaufen
aber am wichtigsten das Mittagessen auf
dem Händler treffen
hinter mir ist eine der berühmtesten
verwählers von Caracas eine Art Marke
der Hauptstadt Venezuelas niemand kann
sagen wie viele Menschen in diesen Slums
leben
[Musik]
wir haben gehört das Lebensmittelketten
wie Papa john's Subway kryptowährung
akzeptieren wir werden das jetzt mal
ausprobieren dieser Aufkleber hier heißt
eigentlich dass die kryptowährung
akzeptieren hallo was ist das ich kann
mit Dash Bezahlen im Moment geht das
leider nicht ich brauche ein Smartphone
und bin kurz zu scannen den sie auf
ihren Telefon erhalten um die
Transaktion abzuschließen aber der Chef
hat das Handy mitgenommen wie viele
Personen bezahlen hier mit
kryptowährungen ist das beliebt
wenn die Ausrüstung am Wochenende hier
ist haben wir manchmal vier Leute an
einem Tag
auf meiner Reise durch Venezuela stellte
sich heraus wie unbequemes ist jedes Mal
wenn ich etwas einkaufen möchte
entweder musste ich jemandem mein Handy
geben damit er es hinter der Kasse
einscannen kann oder ich musste darauf
warten dass der Manager oder Eigentümer
mit seinem eigenen Smartphone kommt um
die Zahlung anzunehmen
es gab einen Vertrauensproblem entweder
wollten Besitzer ihr eigenes
Mobiltelefon nicht den Mitarbeitern
überlassen oder ihnen nicht erlauben das
eigene Handy zu nehmen und das Wallet
runterzuladen um am Ende des Tages die
Transaktionen zu übertragen ein weiteres
Problem waren Händler die ihre wallets
ausdrucken und den ganzen Tag offen
liegen ließen so dass jeder genau sehen
konnte wie viele Transaktionen getätigt
worden waren und wie viel Dash sie
eingenommen hat
im Moment funktioniert das noch aber um
die Kapazität von
QR-Code scanning und der blockchain
Technologie zu nutzen um
Sekundenschnelle Dash Transaktionen zu
ermöglichen würden wir eine bessere
Lösung brauchen
also fingen wir an etwas zu entwickeln
das wir heute
elektro-painen
in diesem Moment schließen wir die
Entwicklungen in unserem Werk in China
ab und schon bald werden wir 25.000
Einheiten pro Monat herstellen können
während unserer Woche in Kolumbien
besorgten ich und nennt so ein kameda
der Entwickler dieses Abrechnungssystems
ein paar Prototypen um sie zu testen und
Händlern zu zeigen sie lieben es und
wollten es sofort kaufen und jetzt sehen
Sie mal wie einfach dieses
kostengünstige Abrechnungssystem
funktioniert
[Musik]
aber wie kommen wir von einem Händler
der Dash akzeptiert im januar 2018 zu
mehr als 350 Unternehmen in weniger als
zwölf Monaten
oder indem wir eine Anzeige bei Google
oder Facebook schalten
dieser Prozess erfordert tausende von
Stunden hunderte von treffen hohe
managementskompetenz tägliche Schulungen
von Händlern und Ladenbesitzern und
jedes einzelnen Mitarbeiters
und das digitale dashquallet
funktionieren
man braucht das direkte Gespräch mit
jedem einzelnen muss ihm dieselbe
Geschichte erzählen in wenigen Minuten
alles über Geld Wirtschaft und
Technologie erklären
das ist eine Menge Arbeit vom ersten
Kontakt zum Händler über den zweiten
Besuch bis hin zum Abschluss wenn wir
den Laden mit Aufklebern und wallets
ausrüsten und vor allem Sie darüber
informieren dass Sie jetzt teil eines
globalen Netzwerks sind es ist auch sehr
wichtig jedem Ladenbesitzer zu erklären
wie Sie Ihre Buchhaltung führen und wo
sie die digitale Währung in Papiergeld
eintauschen können um ihre Lieferanten
und Mitarbeiter zu bezahlen
die Zeit die wir in dieses Projekt
investieren weil die Arbeitsstunden all
die Stunden unterwegs jeder einzelne
Händler zählt jedes einzelne treffen
zählt jede einzelne Person jeder
einzelne Download eines wallets und vor
allem all die Enthusiasten und die
Menschen die das kryptowährungssystem
laufen bringen wollen und die vielen
treffen und Schulungen sind dafür da um
sicherzustellen dass jeder weiß wie man
einen Wallet runterlädt wie man einen
Backup macht und sein Kapital in
geeigneter Weise sichert
wenn man die Bodenhaftung behält und auf
die Händler zugeht dann merkt man dass
Hunderte von Ihnen bereit sind ihre
Räumlichkeiten zur Verfügung zu stellen
für Meetings Veranstaltungen und
individuelle Schulungen
all das wurde auch sehr professionelle
Weise gemacht und vor allem alles wurde
abgerechnet
heute haben wir in unserem dash-netzwerk
weitere Mitarbeiter die jeden einzelnen
Antrag überprüfen um sicherzustellen
dass das Kapital auf faire Weise
ausgegeben wird
heute ist der Columbia geführt von
George Donnelly das beste Beispiel für
gute Führung innerhalb unseres Netzwerks
hallo ich bin George donelli ich bin vor
11 Wochen losgezogen um zu beweisen dass
die groß angelegte Einführung von
kryptowährungen nicht nur möglich ist
sondern dass die Leute danach hungern
und dass das sehr effektiv und
nachhaltig und zu geringen Kosten geht
und wir haben es geschafft
vor elf Wochen gab es noch keinen
einzigen der schändler in Kolumbien dem
Land mit der drittstärksten Bevölkerung
in Lateinamerika und Nachbar von
Venezuela
heute gibt es mehr als 95
[Musik]
40 Prozent sind Restaurants
26% sind Einzelhandelsgeschäfte und der
Rest ist alles mögliche vom Barbier und
Schneider bis hin zur Motorradwerkstatt
und einem Hotel
dieses Mal das sind kleine Läden mit
weniger als 5 Mitarbeitern in denen auch
der Eigentümer regelmäßig anwesend ist
wir fanden sie indem wir uns in den
Straßen von Medellin die Schuhsohlen
abgelatscht haben um zehn nein für ein
Jahr zu bekommen
Centro comercial Monterey
in einem Viertel haben wir jetzt fast 20
der Händler in einem Radius von vier
Häuserblocks
jeder neue Händler bekommt nachdem er
eine Einführung bekommen und ein Dash
Wallet installiert hat einen pay with
Dash Aufkleber und einen kleinen Dash
AirDrop
wir bringen unseren Händlern neue mit
dashzahlende Kunden und führen direkt
Transaktionen mit Ihnen durch
haben gehen Sie zu den Geschäften zurück
und geben es aus auch wenn wir nicht da
sind
wir unterstützen unsere dashändler mit
einem bei Backprogramm so bauen wir
vertrauen auf und erweitern den
dashhandel damit die Händler wissen dass
der echtes Geld ist
und dass sie dieser Währung vertrauen
können
mit kostengünstigen digitalen Medien
bauen wir eine Beziehung zu unseren
neuen Nutzern und Händlern auf
und währenddessen entwickelten wir eine
neue Strategie denn Fakt ist normale
Menschen haben keine Zeit stundenlang in
Meetings oder Klassenräumen zu sitzen um
sich detaillierte Vorträge über
blockchain-technologie anzuhören
wir wollen in wenigen Minuten darüber
informiert werden was das Besondere an
Dash ist
und noch viel lieber wollen sie es
selbst kennenlernen und mit uns per
Telefonkontakt halten
also taten wir genau das ich nenne es
die kostengünstige Händler zentrierte
Strategie
wir sind hier mit einer Gruppe von
sandwich-verkäufern
sie hatten zuerst Bitcoin aber es war
einfach zu verdammt teuer und jetzt
nehmen Sie lieber Dash
ein Teil unserer Arbeit wurde unabhängig
von einem anderen Mitglied der
dash-gemeinde überprüft und was die
Anzahl der Händler betrifft steht
Kolumbien weltweit an achter Stelle und
dann Platz zwei in Lateinamerika
unsere Events werden größer Händler
kommen zu uns Verkäufer bringen uns neue
Interessenten
wir sind zuversichtlich dass wir in den
nächsten sechs Monaten 450 oder mehr
neue der Händler in Kolumbien haben
werden
und was gibt einer Währung mehr wert als
die Orte an denen wir sie ausgeben
können
danke für eure Unterstützung Juan und
ich schätzen das sehr und wir arbeiten
jeden Tag daran sicherzustellen dass wir
hier in Kolumbien wichtige und sinnvolle
Ergebnisse erzielen
wenn Verbraucher ihr Grip Handy
Auspacken ist schon kryptowährungen
darauf geladen die sie ausgeben oder mit
der sie handeln können ein richtiges
Arbeitspferd zu einem super
konkurrenzfähigen Preis inklusive
kryptowährungen zum verschleudern wie
cool ist das denn krip orientiert sich
an den Bedürfnissen der Menschen in den
drei Amerikas einem riesigen Markt mit
900 Millionen Männern und Frauen in über
20 Ländern Kunden die sich kein 1000
Dollar Mobilteil leisten können vom
Technik versierten aber preisbewussten
16-Jährigen bis zum 40-jährigen
Kleinunternehmer unabhängig von Alter
Geschlecht ethnischem Hintergrund
Ursprungsland oder Beruf des Angebot das
erste Smartphone das bereits mit
kryptowährung und Krypto wallets
ausgestattet ist für unter 100 Dollar
extrem erfolgreich in Venezuela mit über
66.000 verkauften Geräten
um dieses System auch in Kolumbien
umzusetzen
und voranzubringen ganz besonders in
neuen Märkten wie Medellin
[Musik]
wir hatten diese Woche Trainings und
Beratungssitzungen mit fünf neuen Dash
Marketing-Teams in Lateinamerika
Kolumbien Paraguay Chile Ecuador und
Mexico
working
Brasilien und Dash Argentinien haben wir
einen Vorschlag erarbeitet eine Dash
lat-am-konferenz am Samstag den 27
Oktober in Berlin
hatte sich zur Aufgabe gemacht an die 2
Millionen Menschen stark Gewinne
zulanische migrantengemeinde
heranzutreten und sie zu überzeugen Dash
für Überweisungen zu nutzen sie blieben
skeptisch aber einer von ihnen will Dash
wallets produzieren für Überweisungen
von Kolumbien nach Venezuela
ich helfe ihm mit der Videos die ich im
Februar bei Händlern in Venezuela
gefilmt hatte
inzwischen hat er Spenden von der Fuß
bekommen und ich glaube dass er sein
Ziel erreichen wird
dahinter mit unseren fünf Händlern in
Bogota und Sao Paulo und wir sind mit
Teams in drei weiteren
lateinamerikanischen Ländern im Gespräch
von Dash Sao Paulo und heute haben wir
die erste Veranstaltung mit Dash
Columbia hier in Brasilien
heute bieten wir den Leuten ein
Mittagessen an dass sie mit der
spezialen können kommt also her und
lasst es euch schmecken
[Musik]
in den letzten zwölf Monaten bin ich auf
über 30 Veranstaltungen auf der ganzen
Welt gewesen
aber die meisten von ihnen in
Lateinamerika vier davon in Kolumbien
und ich habe noch keine Gemeinschaft
gesehen die so stark ist wie die Dash
digital cash-community wenn es um die
Erstellung von Inhalten geht um die
Organisation von Events und die
Anwerbung von Händlern
es gibt immer mehr Veranstaltungen in
Lateinamerika vor allem in Kolumbien und
Brasilien
professionelle Arbeit ist extrem wichtig
um zu zeigen wie stark dieses Projekt
ist
und wie das Team dahinter sich bemüht
das alles wahr werden zu lassen in einer
Weise wie wir es noch nirgendwo anders
auf dieser Welt gesehen haben
inzwischen haben wir mehr Unternehmen
die Dash akzeptieren als die meisten
anderen
kryptowährungsprojekte zusammen
nach einer langen Woche ist es an der
Zeit sich auf den Weg zu machen und
einen erholsamen Tag auf dem Land zu
genießen alle Mitstreiter von dashlet m
und Dash Columbia und viele Freunde sind
gekommen um Zeit miteinander zu
verbringen
aber denkt nicht dass wir hier über
Belanglosigkeiten reden
wir können einfach nicht aufhören über
kryptowährungen blockchain und den
ganzen Papierkram zu sprechen
darüber wie wir die Akzeptanz erhöhen
mehr Bildungsprogramme entwickeln können
und das allerwichtigste wie können wir
all die verschiedenen dash-gemeinden
zusammenbringen
[Musik]
die Hauptfrage ist was ist der wahre
Wert von kryptowährung
er gibt er sich nur aus den Diagrammen
oder aus der Gemeinschaft die dahinter
steht
[Musik]
ich bin mir nicht sicher was ich von
Venezuela erwarten soll es ist das erste
Mal dass ich dort Hinreise aber als
Latino als Brasilianer wird der
Kulturschock wohl nicht allzu groß sein
ich ruhe mich besser mal aus das ist nur
der erste Flug danach warten in Panama
auf Flug Nummer 2 aber bevor wir am Ziel
ankommen werfen wir einen kurzen Blick
in die Geschichte Venezuelas um die
aktuelle Situation vor Ort besser zu
verstehen
[Musik]
beginnen wir mit der Lage Venezuelas
Venezuela liegt an einem strategisch
günstigen Ort auf dem Planeten es
verfügt über 77 Milliarden barrel-öl
Reserven
das brachte Venezuela in eine der
Spitzenpositionen der Länder mit
Ölreserven und das gibt auch jedem
Präsidenten das Gefühl von Macht
wurde 1998 gewählt und galt als der Mann
der Gewinne zu Lana aus der Armut führen
sollte indem er die Ölreserven
Venezuelas nutzte er hatte nur ein Pferd
auf das Servietten konnte und sein Pferd
war Öl weil ein Öl fast damals
durchschnittlich 100 $ kostet der viel
Geld und viel politische Macht
mehrere Sozialprogramme für
Gesundheitsfürsorge Ernährung und
Bildung die alle von der Regierung
bezahlt wurden er verließ sich zu 100%
aufs Öl und voll zog einen massiven
sozialen wandela mit all dem Geld und
der Macht beschloss Jarvis alle
Unternehmen die mit seiner Regierung
verbunden waren zu verständlichen
durch den Kauf aller Banken
zementunternehmen Elektrounternehmen und
viele mehr erlangte der Staat
vollständige Kontrolle über sie in
the mentality time was that und die
Mentalität zu der Zeit war das Venezuela
genug Geld hatte um von Autos über
Lebensmittel Geräte Medikamente Kleidung
landwirtschaftliche Produkte bis hin zu
allem was die Bevölkerung brauchte zu
importieren dabei zerstörte die
Regierung die gesamte
Produktionskapazität des Landes ohne ein
Wirtschaftsmodell oder einem
Geschäftsplan aber der Ölboom dauerte
nur von 2004 bis 2014
und Rücklagen für die Zeit danach wurden
durch die Regierung nicht gebildet den
Nordsee
five Person Export 2012 machte der
Ölexport 95% der venezianischen
Wirtschaft aus und die Ölpreise lagen
bei über 100 $ gleichzeitig begann sich
der Gesundheitszustand von Hugo Chavez
zu verschlechtern was Verunsicherung mit
sich befinde
einige andere Länder hörten damit auf
Venezuela Geld zu leihen das Endergebnis
war der Verfall der Landeswährung und
das ganze Land erlierte einen
wirtschaftlichen Kollaps
has side
Krebs und seine rechte Hand Maduro wurde
zum Präsidenten gewählt
Präsident Maduro erbte ein vom
ölabhängiges das organisiertes Land von
nun an spielte es keine Rolle mehr wer
das Amt des Präsidenten ausübte
eine Lösung für all die Probleme sollte
nicht leicht und erst recht nicht
schnell zu finden sein
international community Präsident Maduro
wurde von der internationalen
Gemeinschaft nicht sonderlich geschätzt
gleichzeitig kollabierten die Ölpreise
Venezuela hatte keine Einnahmen mehr und
das verschärfte die Lage zusätzlich
löste eine die sanitäre Katastrophe aus
die sich durch alle Schichten zogen
s die Armut in Venezuela nahm enorm zu
Güter wurden knapp Supermarktregale
blieben leer weil der Ölpreis weiter
sank versankt Venezuela in Schulden die
Regierung hatte nicht genug Geld um
notwendige Dinge wie Lebensmittel oder
Medikamente für die Bevölkerung zu
kaufen innerhalb weniger Tage
verschwanden landesweit weitere Produkte
aus dem Geschäft
[Musik]
schwere Sanktionen der USA machten es
Venezuela zu den unmöglich das Geld
aufzubringen um seine Schulden zu
begleichen und das Land aus der Armut zu
holen from
20007 von 2013 bis 2017 brachte der
Zusammenbruch der Wirtschaft
Hyperinflation die Abwertung der
Landeswährung boliva erhöhte die Armut
zusätzlich und die von der Regierung
angedachte Lösung des Problems bestand
darin mehr Geld zu drucken viel mehr
Geld doch die Leute nahm das nicht hin
2017 wurden über 10.000 Proteste im Land
registriert durchschnittlich 27
Aufstände am Tag Protest
ich reise nach Venezuela um eine soziale
Revolution mitzuerleben die durch
kryptowährung und die blockchain
befeuert wird wo jeder einzelne
Entscheidungsbefugnis hat und nicht die
Regierung oder die Banken willkommen in
der Dezentralisierung
[Musik]
ich kann es kaum erwarten endlich in
Venezuela anzukommen mein
brasilianischer Pass wird mir sicherlich
dabei helfen ins Land zu kommen außerdem
hat der schwenezuela unter der Leitung
von urinia Alcudia einen straffen
Zeitplan zusammengestellt damit ich all
das sehen kann was das Unternehmen
bereits geleistet hat ich spreche von
einem 12 Stundenplan täglich 7 Tage in
Folge ich werde die Handelskammer
besuchen ich werde als Referent bei zwei
verschiedenen Konferenzen auftreten
außerhalb des Flughafens wartet schon
der Venezuela auf mich das Team hat auch
einen Taxifahrer bestellt der Dash Cash
akzeptiert während der Fahrt vom
Flughafen fällt mir in Venezuelas
Hauptstadt Caracas eine Sache auf man
sieht überall riesige Reklame Tafel mit
dem Bild des Präsidenten und seiner
berühmten kryptowährung aber keine Sorge
hat unter der Leitung auch viele riesige
billboards gebucht und zwar an
strategischen Orten an denen Tausende
von Menschen jeden Tag auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit und zurück vorbeifahren
and the most interestings das
Interessanteste ist dass es auch eine
Hotline gibt unter der man anrufen und
fragen zu Dash tötetal stellen kann die
Nummer wird von der masternote Community
finanziert
eines der Community-Mitglieder von Dash
Venezuela zeigt mir wie viel Geld die
für die Taxifahrt vom Flughafen zum
Restaurant in dem wir essen gehen hätte
bezahlen müssen
gerade einen Betrag von umgerechnet
etwas weniger als 25 US Cent in den
Händen
[Musik]
aber die Taxifahrt haben wir ohnehin mit
der bezahlt
dieser Taxifahrer wird mich jeden Tag
meines Aufenthalts von A nach B bringen
nach einem langen Flug halten wir zum
Brunch dass wir auch mit der
Spezialisten der allein in Venezuela
gibt es über 100 Restaurants die heute
Dash akzeptieren
man sieht den Venezuela häufig
Menschenschlangen in der Öffentlichkeit
vor Supermärkten sowie vor Banken bei
denen die Regierung den Geldbetrag
kontrolliert den man vom eigenen Konto
der Hausbank abheben darf
ich habe dieses Video online gefunden es
zeigt eine verzweifelte Frau die zu spät
bei der Bank ankam und ihr Bargeld nicht
mehr eintauschen konnte bevor die
Regierung die Währung wechselte aus
Protest zerstörte sie alle Banknoten die
jetzt auf einen Schlag nutzlos geworden
waren das war kein Geld mehr das war nur
noch Papier
[Musik]
ich bin in Caracas Venezuela und hier an
der Tankstelle tanke ich für eine der
Kollegen die mich in der Stadt
herumfahren nur damit ihr es wisst ein
Liter Benzin kostet hier ungefähr einen
Boulevard okay wenn ich das Benzin jetzt
mit einem 5 $ Schein bezahlen müsste
würden Sie mir diesen Batzen hier als
Wechselgeld geben
was ich gerade halte entspricht
umgerechnet etwa 75 Cent in US Dollar
aus diesem Grund brauchen wir
kryptowährungen insbesondere in einem
Land gewinnen ein Haufen Geld wie dieser
hier hat sich verändert und ehrlich
sagen für einen Dollar könnte ich hin
Venezuela 6 Monate lang über 200 Autos
volltanken Mann
vorne ist darauf control das gedruckte
Geld ist außer Kontrolle geraten und
Dash ist in über 300 Unternehmen hier in
Venezuela präsent was allen zeigt warum
es wichtig ist eine begrenzte
kryptowährung und ein hervorragendes
Ökosystem wie das von Dash zu haben um
Situationen wie diese zu vermeiden
eine der wichtigsten Dinge die von der
Dash digital Cash Community in Venezuela
entwickelt wurde ist das Dash
merchant-programm
dieses Programm war nur eine vieler
Ideen der Dash caracaskonferenz die auch
andere Community Mitglieder dazu
motivierte eigene Vorschläge zu machen
sodass es ihnen gelungen ist der Digital
Cash bisher über 300 Unternehmen in
Venezuela einzuführen es ist ein
massives adoptionsprogramm im ganzen
Land das auf Händler ausgerichtet ist um
ihr Geschäft zu verbessern aus diesem
Programm heraus entstand auch eine
Website die es jedem Händler ermöglicht
die lokale Währung wo lieber in Dash und
US-Dollar umzurechnen und umgekehrt
[Musik]
so weiß jeder Händler sofort was wie
viel kryptowährung kostet
[Musik]
mein erstes Mal am Venezuela war musste
ich mir selbst erst einmal ein Bild
davon machen wie viele Unternehmen Dash
Akzeptieren von einem medizinischen
Labor das über 50 verschiedene Arten von
Blutuntersuchungen durchführt einem
Elektrogeschäft in dem ihr einen
Fernseher eine Waschmaschine einen
Trockner einen Ofen einen Herd einen
Kühlschrank eine Mikrowelle oder andere
Geräte für zu Hause kaufen könnte
[Musik]
großer Fan von der Arsch dass er sogar
seine mitarbeiteruniform mit dem Dash
Logo versehen hat ein Abschleppdienst
mit über 2000 LKWs der rund um die Uhr
im Einsatz ist hat
sevent
im Einkaufszentrum hat kam das auch in
einer Modekette für Damen nutzen
Venezuela gibt es sogar einen
Motorradladen in dem ihr Motorräder
kriegt die er mit der bezahlt
Dash Force News berichtete dass sich
über 300 Unternehmen bei Discovery Dash
registriert haben und Dash in Venezuela
akzeptieren was eine größere Zahl ist
als in den Vereinigten Staaten obwohl
die Vereinigten Staaten 300 Millionen
Einwohner haben Venezuela nur etwa 30
Millionen heute gibt es in Venezuela 10
mal mehr Unternehmen die Dash
akzeptieren als in den USA
heiraten aber die Dunkelziffer ist
eigentlich noch viel größer Unternehmen
tauschen sich untereinander über die
Einführung von Dash als Bezahlmethode
aus eine Kettenreaktion im Moment weiß
also niemand so genau wie viele
Unternehmen Dash wirklich akzeptieren
das System ist außer Kontrolle sobald
Sie den Vorteil von kryptowährungen
erkennen wechseln Sie sofort dabei haben
die meisten Geschäfte noch nicht einmal
das offizielle das Schöne zu ihrer
Programmen
and most important in my favorite meine
Lieblinge Restaurants viele Restaurants
akzeptieren Dash ich habe sieben Tage in
Venezuela verbracht jeden Tag in einem
anderen Ort gefrühstückt zu Mittag und
zu Abend gegessen und mit der bezahlt
von Cafés bis hin zu frühstückslokalen
Happy Hours und natürlich gängigen
Restaurants und teuren Restaurants die
alle Dash akzeptieren
eine der Strategien von der ich
venezuela ist es Ihre Klienten beim
Start zu begleiten sie laden zu
Versammlungen und Fortbildungen in der
Stadt ein hier hat man sich in einem
Café getroffen dass selbst auch Dash
akzeptiert das Thema dieses Treffens war
das food truckgeschäft in Venezuela und
wie der stimmbetreiber im
Geschäftsalltag helfen könnte
[Musik]
ein weiterer Vorschlag der von der zuvor
erwähnten Konferenz des der schwenezuela
Teams stammt heißt Dash herb wo es eine
lokale Rufnummer gibt unter der jeder
von Montag bis Freitag von 8 bis 9
Fragen zu Dash sogar technische Fragen
dazu stellen kann
wir sprechen mit den Leiter Alessandro
herzlich willkommen wie geht es Dir
Rodrigo willkommen bei Dash help das
hier ist es das ist unser Support-Center
also ja das ist phänomenal weil es ein
echter Bürostandort ist und das ist
nicht alles es gibt noch drei weitere
Räume mit der schändler ja es gibt eine
Küche in der alle Mitarbeiter essen
können und wir haben einen
Besprechungsraum indem wir jetzt gerade
die Fußball-WM übertragen damit jeder
die Spiele sehen kann
diesen Raum nutzt ihr sonst für
Schulungen und Konferenzen es gibt einen
Beamer wir müssen das hier alles mal
zeigen es gibt eine Rezeption okay lass
uns zunächst einmal darüber sprechen wie
viele Personen hier in Vollzeit
beschäftigt sind
hier bei der deshalb haben wir einen
teichmanager und vier Supp Mitarbeiter
im Büro haben wir gerade den Tech
Manager und 3 supportagenten nachmittags
kommt der andere der vierte supportagent
wir haben also fünf Mitarbeiter im
dash-hilfe Support Center und im der
schändler-team haben wir noch weitere
Leute aber wir sprechen ja gleich noch
über das Station
lass uns auch über das dash-händler-team
sprechen wie viele Leute sind im Dash
Händler Team
in der shantler-team haben wir gerade
eine neue Person dazu bekommen wir haben
also den Produktmanager den
Verkaufsleiter das sind zwei und wir
haben acht Verkäufer und wir haben zwei
Assistentin der Geschäftsleitung die die
Verkaufsagenten im Büro unterstützen ich
denke also hilft ist 12 Leute in der
Champions
ist es wichtig zu erwähnen dass alle
Mitarbeiter mit der bezahlt werden
und das ist nicht alles es gibt ja auch
noch die das jugendwinnezuela
Dash Jugend venezuela ist eine
Organisation die sich auf die
Verbreitung von Wissen über das
dash-netzwerk und kryptowährungen
konzentriert wir bieten Vorträge an
Schulen und Universitäten an in denen
wir die grundlegenden Aspekte und
Vorteile von Krypto erklären und wie man
das Dash Micro payment Netzwerk als
Lösung für die Situation in Venezuela
nutzen und ein starkes Finanzsystem für
die Zukunft aufbauen kann
die Wirtschaft in Venezuela ist so sehr
zusammengebrochen dass jedes Mal wenn
man die Wörter Geld oder kryptowährung
sagt überall darüber berichtet wird
während meines Aufenthalts wurde ich
eingeladen zusammen mit einem der
wichtigsten TV-Sender über kryptowährung
und der Städte Türkisch zu sprechen für
sie war es schon das dritte mal zu genau
diesem Thema auf diesem Sender in einer
Woche in Venezuela wurde ich von über
vier verschiedenen Fernsehsendern und
Radiosendern interviewt die Gründerin
von der Venezuela spricht ständig im
Fernsehen über Dash ist
[Musik]
über eine kryptowährung und ein
Zahlungssystem hinaus entwickelt und ist
inzwischen auch ein soziales Programm
zur Inklusion das der schöne zögerteam
gibt Neukunden auf
vorstellungsveranstaltungen ein paar
Dollar zum Test um sich mit dem Thema
intensiver zu beschäftigen dabei
verschenken sie das Geld aber nicht
einfach an sie sondern bringen den
Menschen gleichzeitig bei ein erstes
Wallet herunterzuladen und der ist
darauf zu installieren sie zeigen Ihnen
wie man mit einem Krypto wollet und
kryptowährung umgeht sobald Sie Ihre
digitale Brieftasche heruntergeladen
haben erhalten Sie sofort das genau
die Strategie besteht darin Ihnen auch
einen Anreiz zu geben sobald sie das
Geld in Ihrer Brieftasche haben eine der
12 Einrichtungen und Sozialprogramme
auszuwählen die bereits bei der
schwenezuela registriert sind und eine
direkte Spende zu leisten um diese
Einrichtungen zu unterstützen auf diese
Weise werden die Mittel gut investiert
einerseits um Menschen beizubringen wie
man eine Brieftasche herunterlädt der
ist empfängt und sofort sendet und
andererseits um ein soziales Programm
Umfeld aufrecht zu erhalten dass vielen
Menschen in Venezuela geholfen hat
anstatt Geld kostenlos an irgendjemanden
zu verschenken geht dieses Geld an
spezielle Sozialprogramme in Venezuela
die sogar dazu beitragen Menschen zu
ernähren
die Verwendung von kryptowährung als
Spende für soziale Programme ist eine
weitere Revolution die Dash nach
wiederzuela bringt ihr Geld fließt
direkt an Menschen die es wirklich
brauchen und nicht an große Unternehmen
um marketing-programme oder Boni für
Manager davon zu bezahlen
ein weiteres Programm das ich erwähnen
möchte stammt von einer anderen
Community der ich auch stolz angehöre
einer Bitcoin cash-community sie nennt
sich Bitcoin Cash und verwendet das
gleiche Spendensystem jeder kann von
überall ein paar Dollar spenden und
damit helfen die Menschen in Venezuela
zu ernähren
ist so ein Erfolg dass ein Ableger
gegründet wurde IBC im Südsudan wo es
auch eine humanitäre Krise gibt in der
Menschen verhungern
aber wartet kurz ich bin in den 80er und
90er Jahren aufgewachsen und die meisten
meiner Lieblingsfilme und ich bin großer
Science-Fiction Fan sprechen alle davon
das Computer die Menschheit übernehmen
und sie dominieren und kontrollieren
werden doch im Moment haben wir
Maschinen die Strom brauchen um ein
digitales gut zu schaffen das verwendet
wird um Menschen zu ernähren das konnte
so niemand vorhersagen daran sieht man
mal wie gespalten diese Technologie ist
[Musik]
der Veranstaltungstag ist mein
Lieblingstag der Woche man kann mit
Stolz sagen dass ich über 1.000 Menschen
für den Vortrag und die Präsentation und
die anschließende Dash City angemeldet
haben wenn ihr heute irgendeine Art von
Veranstaltungen Venezuela organisiert
und das Wort Geld in den Mund nehmen
werden tausende von Menschen stundenlang
Schlange stehen um Teil dieser
Veranstaltung zu sein und etwas Neues zu
lernen
[Musik]
bei der Dash digital Cash Konferenz war
das nicht anders in meinem Vortrag ging
es um die Geschichte des Geldes und wie
Brasilien innerhalb von 15 Jahren eine
Inflation von über 1,2 Billionen Prozent
hatte die Regierung änderte den Namen
des Geldes 7 mal Strich 3 Nullen änderte
den Namen des Geldes und druckte neue
Scheine manipulierte die Wirtschaft und
verursachte viele Jahre lang einen
massenchaos in Brasilien wir hatten
sogar einen Präsidenten in Brasilien der
in den 90er Jahren das Geld jedes
Bürgers von seinem Sparkonto in
Brasilien beschlagnahmt hat und heute
geht Venezuela den gleichen Weg wie
Brasilien in den 80er und 90er Jahren
mit Hyper Inflation Abwertung das Geldes
und ohne Kontrolle der Geldmenge
control of Printy
der Vortrag war ein Erfolg und jetzt ist
es an der Zeit zum coolsten Teil des
Events überzugehen Dash city
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch an die paar Dollar die
jeder während der Veranstaltung beim
einchecken und anmelden für die
Konferenz bekommen hat nun jetzt ist es
an der Zeit das Geld auszugeben Dash
City ist ein gut organisierter
Marktplatz mit über 100 Händlern und
Unternehmen die Dash akzeptieren und der
findet direkt im Anschluss an die
Konferenz statt alle Konferenzteilnehmer
sind begeistert von den neuen
Möglichkeiten die Dash und
kryptowährungen ihnen bieten und sie
haben jetzt die Möglichkeit mit Dash ein
Getränk und eine Mahlzeit zu kaufen oder
etwas Geld draufzulegen und ein paar
Goodies zu besorgen die dieser Markt
bietet das ist das beste Beispiel dafür
wie Dash unternehmensgelder sinnvoll
investiert werden können
[Musik]
nach zehnstündiger Veranstaltung den
Vortrag und Dash City ist es an der Zeit
sich hinzusetzen das Studio einzurichten
und Inhalte für Dash Venezuela und der
Brasilien aufzunehmen the power of
Community wenn es so alles so strong die
Kraft der Gemeinschaft in Venezuela ist
so stark dass sie bis heute über 22
Community Manager hervorgebracht hat die
sich darum kümmern der sich in ihre
Viertel oder Städte rund um Caracas oder
maracai zu bringen sie erhalten eine
einfache Anleitung von der Venezuela
Tipps dazu wie man neue Partner gewinnt
und den Geschäftsausbau fördern kann sie
verändern die Gesellschaft und
akzeptieren eine neue Art des Geldes wir
haben über 25 Interviews mit Community
Managern geführt und Ihnen eine einfache
Frage gestellt wie können sie
Geschäftsinhaber am besten davon
überzeugen kryptowährungen zu
akzeptieren den Community Managern freie
Hand zu lassen sich auf ihr Umfeld und
die lokale Wirtschaft einzulassen war
die beste Entscheidung
[Musik]
jetzt ist es an der Zeit rauszugehen und
nach marokkai der zweitgrößten Stadt
Venezuelas zu fahren dort wartet ein
weiteres Vorhaben das von der Master not
Community einen Team von Titanen
genehmigt wurde
seine Industrie und die vielen Fabriken
bekannt im Industriesektor des Landes
steckt großes Potential für dich indem
[Musik]
ich wurde eingeladen vor der Handels-
und industriekammer von maracay zu
sprechen und vor etwa 400 Gästen eine
weitere Präsentation zu halten der
beherd
[Musik]
das Beste seit Beginn der erstbewegung
in Venezuela und der Leitung von Eugenia
alcali und der Dash caracaskonferenz ist
das Interesse an Dash in dem
südamerikanischen Land explodiert die
bargeldähnlichen Funktion von Dash für
private sofortüberweisungen mit extrem
niedrigen Gebühren werden als
Wegbereiter für finanzielle Stabilität
angesehen neue Projekte wie Krypto life
x Kalibers get free Dash Venezuela und
mehr haben die Bewegung zusätzlich
befeuert der verbreitet sich im ganzen
Land doch das Thema dieses Interviews
mit Hilfe eines Dolmetschers habe ich
mit dem Team gesprochen dass sich in
Venezuelas zweitgrößter Stadt für die
Einführung von Dash einsetzt und mit
einem vorläufigen Antrag an die
Schatzkammer des der Netzwerker
angetreten ist ich hoffe euch gefällt
das Interview mit Dash Marei
nahm seine Arbeit auf nachdem der Sohn
eines der Mitglieder an einer der ersten
Venezuela Konferenzen in Caracas
teilgenommen hatte und heute haben sie
einen der ambitioniertesten Vorschläge
für Dash für die ganze Stadt angeführt
von einem Team extremer Fachleute
darunter der CEO der immobilienkammer
der Präsident der Industrie- und
Handelskammer der Vizepräsident für
Immobilien und der Kammer von Venezuela
und dem Direktor der immobilienkammer
and today aktuell führt man Gespräche
darüber Dash als Zahlungsmittel für alle
Beschäftigten im Industrie und
Produktionssektor der Region einzuführen
das ist ein weiterer Schritt in Richtung
einer
kryptowährungsrevolution
das die Einführung einer digitalen
Währung durchaus positive Effekte auf
die Stabilität eines Landes haben kann
zeigt sich am Beispiel Venezuela das
Startup value hilft den Menschen in
Venezuela im Kampf gegen die
Hyperinflation
[Musik]
ich bin Mitbegründer und CEO von value
unser Produkt hilft in venezueladern mit
der Hyperinflation umzugehen und ihr
Geld vor Wertverlust zu schützen
Überweisungen zu erhalten vor Ort zu
bezahlen und um Lebensmittel und
Medikamente zu kaufen
sowohl Unternehmen als auch Verbraucher
sind in der Lage waren und
Dienstleistungen miteinander zu tauschen
und in kryptowährung zu bezahlen unsere
Vision ist es die wirtschaftliche
Freiheit zu erhöhen
venezuela ist bekannt für seine
politische und wirtschaftliche
Instabilität die Hyperinflation hat dazu
geführt dass der boliva in nur zwei
Jahren 99 Prozent seines Wertes verloren
wohlhabende Familien sahen ihr Vermögen
schwinden und einkommensschwache
Menschen wurden noch weiter in die
Verzweiflung getrieben
Simon schamoro kennt diese Geschichte
nur allzu gut
als ich in Venezuela aufwuchs ging im
Grunde alles was mein Vater und meine
Mutter in ihrem Leben aufbauen konnten
verloren als die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrach
wir hatten zum Beispiel Wasserknappheit
oder Stromausfälle im ganzen Land das
Geld fing an Hyper inflationär zu werden
das ist keine traurige Geschichte die
ich hier versuche zu erzählen das ist
leider die Realität der meisten
Venezolaner mehr als 99 Prozent der
Venezolaner haben alles verloren was sie
aufgebaut haben weil das Land
gescheitert ist alle Ersparnisse aus der
Mittelschicht die sich etwas aufbauen
wollte lösten sich in Luft auf ich
wollte meine Bestimmung finden und
wusste immer dass ich ein Unternehmen
gründen und Dinge entwickeln wollte
weshalb ich dann auch Industriedesign
studierte ich glaubte fest daran in der
Lage zu sein Dinge zu verändern
letztendlich habe ich diese Karriere
nicht weiter verfolgt aber ich habe eine
Menge Dinge gelernt die mir die
Technologie näher gebracht haben und so
bin ich beim Thema Krypto gelandet ich
habe mich dafür begeistert und als ich
dann das Potenzial von Krypto verstanden
wurde mir klar dass Venezuela der
perfekte Ort ist um solche Ideen in
große Maßstab umzusetzen
der reality ist tatsächlich könnte eine
dekonstruierung der kryptowährung der
Mittelschicht helfen und dieser hat die
Möglichkeit unsere Gesellschaft wie wir
sie kennen grundlegend zu verändern
das Hauptproblem der Venezolaner ist im
Moment die Hyperinflation und diese ist
nur das Nebenprodukt einer totalen
Misswirtschaft dieses Landes
[Musik]
Venezuelas Abstieg in eine verarmte
Diktatur hat der Welt die verheerenden
Auswirkungen der Hyperinflation vor
Augen geführt schleppende
Grundversorgung extreme Knappheit an
Lebensmitteln und medizinischen Mitteln
andere stabilere Währungen wie den
US-Dollar transferieren konnten blieben
verschont ein Luxus der meist nur für
die Ultra Elite in Frage kam
mittels kryptowährung möchte Simon mit
seiner Plattform value allen die
Möglichkeit geben sich gegen die
Hyperinflation zu wehren
seiner Meinung nach sind die instabilen
Verhältnisse in seinem Land der
perfekten Nährboden für ein solches
Experiment
niemand traut mehr der Währung oder der
Regierung die Menschen suchen nach
Lösungen
an einem Ort an dem die Menschen
versuchen zu überleben ist die
Hemmschwelle viel niedriger neue Dinge
auszuprobieren sei es diese Dollars
tischmünzen kryptowährungen die Leute
werden bereit sein mit wenig Geld zu
starten und dann langsam versuchen es
irgendwie zu etablieren unser Hauptziel
im Moment als Unternehmen ist es
Händlern zu ermöglichen den Ditto Dollar
als Zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren so
dass die Leute immer weniger gezwungen
sind im Boulevard zu benutzen
wir konzentrieren uns darauf ein Produkt
zu entwickeln das von den Reichen
gebildeten und technisch versierten bis
hin zu den Menschen mit den niedrigen
Einkommen und geringen technischen
Kenntnissen genutzt werden kann in einem
Land wie Venezuela wurde der Mindestlohn
bei ungefähr einem Dollar liegt haben
sie die Situation dass die meisten Leute
ihr eigenes kleines Geschäfte eröffnen
Hot Dogs verkaufen oder lokales Essen
wie arrepas oder was auch immer aber sie
verkaufen es vorwiegend in ihren super
riesigen Gemeinden also wollen wir den
Gemeinden helfen Zahlungen in Dollar bzw
in dito Dollar also stable Coins zu
akzeptieren und Nutzer zu erreichen je
mehr Verbraucher in Dollar zahlen desto
besser für die Händler je mehr Händler
als akzeptieren umso besser für die
Verbraucher bis heute haben wir
Millionen von Dollar bewegt und haben
damit mehr als 150.000 Haushalten
geholfen
30.000 aktive Nutzer monatlich und wir
sehen dass es funktioniert in
Wirklichkeit kann wirtschaftliche
Freiheit nur direkt durch Innovation
erreicht werden was kryptowähr sind
dabei darf man nicht vergessen dass
Venezuela dies bereits versucht hat el
Petro war der Versuch einer
kryptowährung zu etablieren die durch
die reichhaltigste Ressource des Landes
unterstützt wurde Öl während el Petro
weithin als durchschlagender Misserfolg
betrachtet wurde sind sich viele
Experten einig dass dieses Experiment
ein notwendiger Schritt war um eine
digitale Währung für die Zukunft zu
etablieren und Simon ist überzeugt dass
deren Grundlage nämlich die
blockchain-technologie nun stärker denn
je benötigt wird und sein Land bereit
ist für einen weiteren Versuch
die blockchain-technologie ist
tatsächlich eine Art Paradigmenwechsel
für die Menschheit eines der
bedeutsamsten Dinge unserer Zeit
man sieht langsam dass immer mehr
Unternehmen damit beginnen ihre Produkte
komplett auf einer blockchain aufzubauen
es ist fast so als würde sich eine
eigene Wirtschaft entwickeln
wenn es einen Weg ohne Krypto gäbe den
venezulanern ihre Stabilität und
wirtschaftliche sowie finanzielle
Freiheit zurückzugeben wäre das
natürlich ein viel besserer Weg als mit
einem Produkt Erfolg zu haben dass in
sich gar keinen Wert besitzt
[Musik]